so when a couple of months ago we got
these really wild polls
nationally polls that had donald trump
down to joe biden by 10 points
nationally by 12 points nationally there
were even a few that said donald trump
was down by 15 points nationally
i said at the time whether or not
those polls were accurate at the time
and remember accurate means within the
margin of error so if it says 15 it
could really be
eight uh depending on the margin of
error i repeated at the time
it is very unlikely that on election day
we're going to see a 10-point margin in
the popular vote it's just
extraordinarily unlikely
uh i i don't think any of us should be
imagining that that's the case we should
imagine it's going to be much tighter
and it means we all have to vote
at the same time if these polls keep
coming out we can't really ignore them
and indeed there are now multiple new
polls that have joe biden up by 12.
there is a new reuters ipsos poll which
says that joe biden leads donald trump
by 12 points nationally that's among
likely voters 52 to 40.
there's also a new usc poll which says
joe biden is up by 12 and importantly in
that one joe biden is polling at 53
so in both the reuters ipsos poll in the
usc poll
not only is donald trump losing by
double digits but joe biden is over 50
support which is an important metric to
keep an eye on now
in these polls somewhere between three
and five percent of likely voters say
they're just undecided right now
now i've talked about this before who
are those people
how could you possibly be undecided at
this point unless you've literally not
paid attention to politics and in that
case
how likely are you to actually vote
that's a question if we say
the electorate is expected to be about
130 million people
if five percent are undecided um
that is six and a half million voters
right now six and a half million voters
who are looking at this situation and
saying
i might vote biden or i might vote trump
i continue to be stunned and appalled by
that reality i would love to talk to
some of those undecided voters i
invite you to call in i've not heard
from any of them so far
now it's really important to remember
that
a popular vote margin correlates
differently to the likelihood of an
electoral victory for democrats versus
republicans there is a
structural imbalance against democrats
where as you know
sometimes democrats win the popular vote
and don't become president because they
lose the electoral college as i'm sure
you remember
um unless you're four years old in which
case i don't even know that we have
four-year-olds in our audience
in 2016 donald trump lost the popular
vote by 2.1
but he won the electoral college thanks
to 70-something
thousand votes in three states nate
silver
from 538 did something important he
crunched the numbers to tell us
given a particular popular vote margin
how likely is it that joe biden will win
the electoral college
and again understand that the numbers
are skewed in this way
because of the urban rural divide and
because of some other
sort of base level factors that favor
republicans in the electoral college
uh even at the even while
being at a disadvantage in the popular
vote so
if joe biden wins the popular vote by
under one point his odds of becoming
president of
getting 270 electoral votes are only six
percent
if joe biden can win the popular vote by
one to two points
he has a 22 percent chance of winning
the electoral college
if joe biden matches hillary clinton's
popular vote win
somewhere in the two to three point
range it is still slightly more likely
that trump wins the electoral college in
other words if
biden gets a similar margin of victory
in the popular vote to hillary
he only has a 46 chance of winning the
electoral college
that's why we all have to vote only when
joe biden's popular vote lead gets
beyond three points
does joe biden become the likely
candidate to become president if he wins
between three and four points in the
popular vote
he has a 74 percent chance of being
president and as you can see
if joe biden were to get a six point
popular vote win the odds of becoming
president
go above 99 if in some
other universe joe biden actually were
to win the popular vote by 10.
um it would be all but certain that he
becomes the next president of the united
states so
that's how i would be thinking about the
popular vote
versus the electoral vote scenario now
let's look at joe biden's average lead
right now because
the 12 point lead is not representative
of the average if you look at joe
biden's
average in all national polls he's up by
6.9
okay if joe biden were to win by 6.9
as i just showed you he will almost
certainly win the electoral college
right well yes and no if he really wins
by 6.9 yes
but remember that there is a margin of
error here now
when you're averaging poll results
you can't just say okay biden's up by
6.9
if the average poll has a 3 margin of
error for each candidate that means
maybe joe's only up by 0.9
there are some complex mathematics
involved in figuring out
an overall margin of error when you're
already
averaging poll results which in and of
themselves have margins of error
it doesn't matter the point is uh
hillary clinton ended up with a popular
vote win
that was two-thirds the size of what the
polling predicted so let me put it a
different way
hillary clinton was expected to win by
three in the polls
she won by two that means her real
margin was
two-thirds of the expected margin
if we apply that to joe biden if we say
okay
biden is winning by 6.9
but we're only expecting him to win by
two-thirds of that
that would be about a four-point popular
vote margin of victory
if that were the case it still doesn't
guarantee
victory for joe biden but it certainly
starts to look pretty good
what does this mean this means we all
have to vote
that's really all that this means and
even though the popular vote numbers may
be looking pretty good
we do have to talk about something
that's going on in minnesota which is
not looking quite so good
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
when you go to davidpakman.com watch
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about 200
but it'll look like you spent a lot more
all of their watches are made in small
batches from
top quality materials and they just look
great i went on their site and picked
out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 percent off everything in
their store when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch and i've put that link right
underneath this video